at just 21 years old Daisy Ridley was
far from an established action hero when
she was cast as Rey in Star Wars The
Force awakens in fact she was all but
unknown her career up to that point had
been mainly minor roles and small
British productions with no onset
explosions or fight scenes to speak of
so hell did Ridley get herself in action
star shape to join the sprawling Star
Wars saga let's take a look at lots of
focus and food experts agree when it
comes to getting cuts nutrition is far
more important than exercise in
sculpting and eye-catching body in red
Lee's case the already slim actress
wasn't trying to lose weight for her
role but rather bulk up to look strong
and ready to fight the first order I had
to put on muscle so I was eating a lot
and I love to eat they caught two
pointers that I feel sick it's telling
you to eat you're having me to eat you
know to say oh but a high-calorie diet
isn't a license to eat empty calories
like ice cream and drink beer all day
otherwise everyone would be doing it
instead Ridley ate a healthy
high-calorie diet consisting of foods
loaded with protein which is an
essential ingredient to growing muscle
training as therapy Ridley started a
training just a few weeks after she
learned she got the role of Rae buckling
down on a regimen of 5 hour a day 5 day
a week workouts speaking to Elle Ridley
said she came around to a mindset in
which the lengthy workout routines felt
like more of a blessed oasis in a day
rather than an unwelcome interruption in
her life it became my solace as the only
thing structured in my life right now
training is sort of a therapy session I
guess a combination of disciplines while
training for the force awakens with the
chronic order fitness journey on
Instagram earning fans with popular
Fitness Friday posts that have since
been deleted that live on through the
archival efforts of her online followers
in the videos you can see her engaging
in a little bit of everything in the gym
from resistance training to tone muscle
to core strength building workouts she
also engaged in activities as diverse as
kickboxing rock climbing and of course
tons of cardio the end result of this
variety of work is overall fitness and
the body that's generally muscular with
no one muscle group exaggerated after
all ray isn't a muscle-bound warrior
she's just a generally fit person and
for the movies sake she needs to look
like it personal trainers the main
trainer really worked
early on was Jack graves a former rugby
player which may have something to do
with the grueling cardio work that went
into our routines but while graves did
the work for Ridley's general fitness
she also worked with more specialized
trainers for activities specific to Star
Wars like swinging swords around in
close quarters combat which saw her
training with a stuntman and
choreographer who also helped design the
fight sequences for the last Jedi and
Ridley told vogue those lightsabers are
heavier than they look weighing in at
about 10 pounds so she really needed the
conditioning they're really heavy three
four five kilos and the weights very
unevenly distributed a positive outlook
in one of Britney's old Instagram posts
she made a point about how what we see
on Instagram really corresponds to
reality and that's a fitness post while
inspiring hardly told the whole story I
have a trainer urging me on in workouts
and I don't include all the times I say
I can't do it what she did include
though was positivity and excitement and
enthusiasm for the work even when she
wasn't at her best as one characteristic
post read for anyone that's gonna try
and correct my form I know it isn't the
best I've just started doing sprint
training so progressing all the time
this sort of positive outlook matters as
just knowing that just because you're
not your best right now it doesn't mean
you won't get better thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to